[Musik]
die korona infektionen steigen weiter
und die gesundheitsämter schlagen alarm
deutschland sei auf eine zweite welle
nicht gut vorbereitet rauswurf aus der
partei thilo sarrazin ist nicht mehr
mitglied der spd entscheidet das höchste
parteiinternen schiedsgericht und
rückschlag für die demokratiebewegung in
hongkong finden dieses jahr keine wahlen
statt offiziell wegen der korona
pandemie
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg der 31 juli guten abend
und willkommen an meiner seite ist
wieder jemand für den sport ein stück
von mir 870 corona neuinfizierte allein
von gestern auf heute seit einiger zeit
wachsen die zahlen wieder und damit auch
die sorge vor einer zweiten welle für
die die gesundheitsämter offenbar nicht
gerüstet sind sie seien noch immer viel
zu knapp besetzt heißt es vom
zuständigen verband vom versuch den
anstieg in den griff zu bekommen
berichtet an seinem stand voll vermummte
antivirus helfer die pandemie deutlich
sichtbar heute im landkreis dithmarschen
schleswig holstein
es wird fleißig getestet etwa an dieser
mobilen station in der stadtheide hier
gelten seit heute wieder strenge regeln
denn es gab viele neuinfektionen
jetzt sind die kontakt beschränkungen
zurück maximal zwei personen aus
unterschiedlichen haushalten dürfen sich
hier noch treffen
man muss wirklich an die leute
appellieren sich an die regeln zu halten
die vorgegeben sind und dann wird es
hoffentlich gut ausgehen alles andere
als gut entwickeln sich die zahlen 870
neuinfektionen meldet das robert koch
institut heute keine momentaufnahme
laut johns hopkins universität haben
sich im schnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage 660 menschen mit corona angesteckt
da wachsen die sorgen vor der zweiten
virus welle auf die vor allem die
wichtigen gesundheitsämter ziemlich
schlecht vorbereitet wären kritisieren
die amtsärzte
es sei zu wenig getan worden dringend
gesucht personal vor allem für die
verfolgung der infektionsketten also ich
glaube es ist ganz dringend notwendig
dass wir kurzfristig unterstützung geben
es wäre vielleicht eine möglichkeit dass
wir eine eine freiwilligenbörse
aufmachen wo sich leute melden können
dass wir das auch zentral organisieren
die interesse oder zeit hätten im
gesundheitsamt dann auszuhelfen
ein appell es ist nicht der einzige das
abstandhalten das achtsam sein lasse
nach etwa beim einkaufen sagt der handel
wir erleben dass wir alle im eigenen
verhalten erleben dass die sorglosigkeit
zunimmt und wir sind von handel seit es
sehr sehr bemüht die regeln auch
anzumahnen aber wir sind keine ersatz
polizei virus krise seit monaten der
wunsch nach leichtigkeit ist groß aber
er ist auch riskant denn die korona lage
in deutschland wird gerade wieder
deutlich schlechter
matthias fornoff ist bei mir mit dem
neuen politbarometer und darin guten
namen zeigen sich veränderungen beim
thema kronen ja denn wie es in der krise
weitergeht hängt entscheidend davon ab
wie jeder einzelne sich an die korona
regeln hält und da hat sich in den
letzten wochen offenbar was verschoben
eine mehrheit 51 prozent jedenfalls
glaubt dass sich die deutschen jetzt
eher unvernünftig verhalten mitte juni
das sehen wir hier rechts sah das noch
ganz anders aus fast zwei drittel sagten
da dass sich die menschen in deutschland
vernünftig verhalten und dieses
veränderte verhalten wird negative
folgen haben das jedenfalls glauben die
meisten 77 prozent also mehr als drei
viertel der befragten erwarten in
nächster zeit eine zweite corona welle
nur jeder fünfte bezweifelt das was ist
mit der angst verstecken meyer die sorge
ist jedenfalls gewachsen
jeder zweite hält jetzt seine gesundheit
für gefährdet vor drei wochen fühlten
sich noch 60 prozent sicher masken
pflicht abstandsregeln fühlen sich die
deutschen da stark eingeschränkt ja
sagen 29 prozent eine deutliche mehrheit
von 71 prozent aber fühlt sich nicht
stark ein
schränkt das sehen die anhänger aller
parteien so nur die anhänger der afg
fühlen sich mehrheitlich mit 59 prozent
eben stark eingeschränkt aber so oder so
die regeln werden noch länger uns gleich
so sieht so ist dankeschön matthias das
ausführliche politbarometer mit matthias
fornoff gibt es im heute journal um 10
und natürlich online in unserer zdf
heute alle fragen alle zahlen nochmal in
ruhe zum nachlesen wer aus nordspanien
aus deutschland zurückreist muss sich
auf strengere regeln einrichten
das robert-koch-institut hat die
regionen nahbarer aragon und katalonien
auf die liste der risikogebiete gesetzt
und das auswärtige amt warnt jetzt vor
einem trip in die region zu der auch die
strände der costa brava und die
metropole barcelona gehören die
erleichterung in der spd dürfte enorm
sein seit zehn jahren versuchen die
sozialdemokraten den umstrittenen
bestseller autor thilo sarrazin
rauszuwerfen mit rassistischen und
islamfeindlichen thesen schade er der
partei
heute nun hat das höchste parteiinternen
schiedsgericht bestätigt der 75-jährige
ist nicht mehr mitglied der spd
nur will sich der nicht damit abfinden
dass busacca details am morgen muss
thilo sarrazin noch warten in der spd
zentrale
ausgerechnet neben der skulptur von
willy brandt dem parteivorsitzenden der
wie kein anderer für völkerverständigung
stand sechs stunden später fällt die
bundesschiedskommission ihr urteil
sarrazin fliegt aus der spd thilo
sarrazin hat sein spd parteibuch
abgegeben er ist nicht mehr mitglied
unserer partei das kapitel thilo
sarrazin ist für uns beendet
er wird künftig seine rassistischen
seiner anti muslimischen thesen nicht
mehr unter dem deckmantel einer
spd-mitgliedschaft verbreiten können
das ist für uns ein wichtiger tag ein
guter tag
es war bereits der dritte anlauf
sarrazin auszuschließen vor zehn jahren
schon
produzierte er seine partei mit dem buch
deutschland schafft sich ab
hier vertrat er thesen die in der spd
als klar ausländerfeindlich bewertet
wurden ein ausschuss verfahren aber
scheiterte damals sein jüngstes werk
feindliche übernahme die ihm die
parteiführung antimuslimischen rassismus
testiert führte jetzt allerdings zum
rausschmiss wenn sie von jemandem
geschimpft werden unmoralisch
abqualifiziert werden als der rassist
und als und als rechtspopulist haben sie
keine wahl als ihren ruf zu verteidigen
und das werde ich tun
thilo sarrazin hat also nicht vor die
entscheidung zu akzeptieren
der ehemalige berliner finanzsenator und
bundesbanker will gerichtlich gegen
seinen ausschluss vor gehen wirklich
abgeschlossen ist der fall also immer
noch nicht für die hongkonger
demokratiebewegung ist es ein schwerer
schlag die für september geplante
parlamentswahl wird verschoben
so hat es regierungschefin lahm
entschieden sie steht der chinesischen
führung nah wie zunehmend massiv in die
geschicke der früheren britischen
kronkolonie eingreift stephanie schöne
baum carol m ist die stellvertreterin
und stimme der chinesischen
regierungschefs ist sie sind und diese
stimme hat heute die parlamentswahlen in
hongkong um ein jahr verschoben
als grund nennt sie corona an steigende
infektionszahlen doch mit keinem wort
spricht die stimme pekings von dem
eingriff in die demokratischen
grundwerte
wir wollen die öffentliche sicherheit
und gesundheit gewährleisten und dass
die wahlen offen fair und unparteiisch
abgehalten
nur ein vorwand sagt die pro
demokratische opposition und diese
meinung teilen viele wenn sie die wahlen
nicht hätten verschieben wollen hätten
sie es doch bekommt es gibt doch auch
andere länder die trotz corona war ein
problemlos durchgeführt haben seit dem
ersten juli seit dem neuen so genannten
sicherheitsgesetz denen die polizei
massiv gegen aktivisten vor nahm
zahlreiche fest
jeder wahlkampfauftritt der pro
demokratischen partei konnte mit einer
festnahme ende gestern wurden zwölf
kandidaten ausgeschlossen wegen
angeblichen verstoßes gegen das
sicherheitsgesetz das ist ein sehr
trauriger tag flach und demokratie in
hongkong und dem prinzip ein land was
wir eindeutig sehen ist freie und faire
wahlen nicht mehr statt
die pro demokratische opposition hatte
gute chancen die wahl zu gewinnen doch
der griff pekings wird immer härter und
die demokratie des einst freien
hongkongs stirbt immer schneller
deutschland hat am abend das
auslieferungsabkommen mit hongkong
ausgesetzt zur begründung sagte
aussenminister maß die verschiebung der
parlamentswahl sei ein weiterer
einschnitt in die rechte der bürger
hongkongs
heute kamen die zahlen wie stark die
wirtschaftsleistung in der eurozone
durch corona gelitten hat für die monate
april bis juni ermittelte die statistik
gehörende euro statt ein minus von 12,1
gegenüber dem ersten vierteljahr
am heftigsten traf es spanien mit minus
18,5 prozent
für deutschland war bereits gestern
einen einbruch von 10,9 prozent gemeldet
worden
die korona situation in den usa wird
immer dramatischer kein land hat mehr
neuinfektionen und tote zu beklagen
mal zu 4,5 millionen menschen haben sich
dort mit dem virus infiziert allein
gestern waren es mehr als 67.000
sozialen der johns-hopkins-universität
152.000 menschen überlegt und die
krankheit nicht aus den usa täten alles
blinkt roth im krankenhaus von naples
florida zeichen dass in jedem der räume
ein komapatient um sein leben ringt im
gesamten bundesstaat liegt die tägliche
todesrate so hoch wie im mai es gibt
kaum noch freie intensivbetten und dann
fünftel der patienten mit schweren
symptomen stirbt sagt dr lindner das ist
für uns alle viel zu hoch wegen der
unvernunft es die pandemie außer kommt
cecelia aus kansas 20 voller lebenslust
bis sie sich anfang juli infizierte
cobit 19 zerstörte einen teil ihrer
lunge
jetzt braucht sie eine neu ich ging raus
in restaurants war mit freunden zusammen
nie hätte ich gedacht dass ich zwei
wochen vor meinem 21
geburtstag meine lunge verlieren immer
mehr menschen in amerika tragen nun
masken aber in vielen bundesstaaten und
städten sind sie weiterhin keine pflicht
trotz hochschnellen der infektionsraten
und der präsident sieht amerika auf dem
weg der besserung
die zahlen gehen runter substanziell sie
gehen auch unter einfluss amerikas
wichtigster gesundheitsexperte
widerspricht ihm heute er wird gefragt
ob es eine bessere nationale strategie
gebraucht hätte es gab so viele
unterschiedliche maßnahmen in den
bundesstaaten aber keine gemeinsame
anstrengungen die zahlen runter zu
drücken
deshalb bringen nun immer mehr menschen
um ihr leben wie hier in naples in
florida der geplante abzug von us
truppen aus deutschland sorgt für ärger
in der großen koalition gestritten wird
über die richtige politische reaktion
empörung allein reiche nicht findet
spd-fraktionschef mütze nicht er stellt
jetzt die rüstungskooperation mit
washington insgesamt in frage
unionspolitiker dagegen warnen davor
vorschnell einen pfeiler
transatlantische zusammenarbeit
einzureißen
da wird gepackt als donald trump vor
eineinhalb jahren amerikanische truppen
in deutschland besuchte war es noch ein
gedankenspiel
nun macht er seine drohung wahr 12.000
us soldaten sollen abgezogen werden
das könne nicht unbeantwortet bleiben
fordert die spd detail abzug
amerikanischer truppen muss natürlich
hier auch auf politische reaktionen
treffen und deswegen bin ich schon der
überzeugung das natürlich auch rüstungs
kooperationen auf dem prüfstand steht
insbesondere war ja offensichtlich der
amerikanische präsident nur die sprache
versteht wenn es um geld wenn es um
rüstungslieferungen geht
der koalitionspartner cdu reagiert
verärgert mit unverständnis
es besteht überhaupt kein grund die
rüstungskooperation aufzugeben das ist
ein wahlkampfmanöver
von muetze nicht dass letztlich trump
zugutekommt wir sollten sehr klar sagen
wir sind auf die transatlantische
zusammenarbeit auch in sicherheitsfragen
angewiesen verteidigungsministerin
kramp-karrenbauer will unter anderem
einen teil der veralteten tornado
kampfjets mit f 18 kampfflugzeuge des us
herstellers boeing ersetzen so
ausgerüstet dass sie im ernstfall
hierzulande stationierte us atombomben
abwerfen könnten
erstens wir sind der auffassung dass
diese atomwaffen abgezogen werden sollen
zweitens wer nach dieser ohrfeige durch
trump im ernst glaubt ihm auch noch geld
hinterher schmeißen zu müssen
wir hatten gar nicht verstanden was
deutsches interesse ist es kann kein
kauf von 11-18 nach dieser vorgeschichte
geben der angekündigte teilabzug der
us-truppen sorgt für ärger in der
koalition und darüber hinaus eine
einheitliche antwort aus deutschland
bleibt aus macht pflege arm wer in einem
heim betreut wird bekommt die steigenden
kosten seit jahren zu spüren
im bundesweiten durchschnitt müssen die
pflegebedürftigen oder ihre angehörigen
mittlerweile über 2000 euro im monat
selbst zahlen sagt der verband der
ersatzkassen
das system müsse dringend geändert
werden frank buchwald pflege im alter
belastend für viele betroffene aber auch
für ihre familien nervlich emotional und
finanziell der eigenanteil an den
pflegekosten steigt seit jahren nun
schlagen die ersatzkassen alarm die
maßnahmen die ja gut und sinnvoll sind
um den pflegenotstand in deutschland zu
bekämpfen also tariflöhne anzuheben und
auch mehr personal einzustellen
aufzustocken den einrichtungen führt
natürlich zu mehrkosten die dann auf der
anderen seite von pflegebedürftigen
wieder zu tragen sind allein seit juli
letzten jahres ist die durchschnittliche
finanzielle belastung eines
pflegebedürftigen in stationärer pflege
von 1891 auf 2015 euro gestiegen im
monat
ein plus von 6,6 oft reicht die rente
dafür nicht patientenschutz erfordern
deshalb mehr steuergeld für die pflege
zur entlastung der angehörigen die
eigenanteile explodieren dann können die
pflegebedürftige das nicht mehr aus
eigener tasche zahlen und pflege macht
arm
das weiß man seit jahren der einzige der
nicht reagiert ist der
bundesgesundheitsminister solche
vorwürfe war es die politik jedoch
zurück das problem längst erkannt
auf betreiben bayerns ist das
angehörigen entlastungsgesetz anfang des
jahres beschlossen worden dh dass
angehörige erst ab einem
jahresbruttoeinkommen von 100.000 euro
auf die zurückgegriffen wird ich finde
das ist ein guter schritt um die
angehörigen auch ein bisschen zu
schützen
eine reform der pflegeversicherung
ursprünglich für den sommer geplant
wurde verschoben wegen krone im herbst
aber soll sie nun kommen sie werden es
alle gemerkt haben
es ist heiß der bislang heißeste tag des
jahres schon am nachmittag meldet trier
37,5 grad fast genauso warm ist es in
rheinfelden an der schweizer grenze
waghäusel bei karlsruhe kommt immerhin
auf 36,2 grad von der freude über die
hitze aber auch von deren kehrseite
berichtet andreas link ein badesee bei
stuttgart im südwesten herrschten die
höchsten temperaturen aber noch sind
hier eher hitze genieße unterwegs ich
liebe es
heute kurzarbeit eigentlich nachteil
aber in dem fall natürlich gut
doch die hitze verstärkt das generelle
problem der dürre in deutschland im
norden des schwarzwalds erwartet
landwirt gerd fastnacht eine um ein
viertel reduziert getreideernte das
problem dass wir in fünf jahren weniger
gras schnitt weniger strom
gerhard fassnacht weiß von kollegen die
tiere verkaufen müssen wegen
futtermangel der dürre monitor weist
große gebiete in deutschland als extrem
trocken aus nur an alpen und küste
herrscht kein wassermangel das sind die
weißen bereiche im osten deutschlands
verschärft sich die dürre besonders auch
wenn das teilweise mit dem wetter zu tun
hat im hintergrund spielt hier die
veränderung im klimasystem eine große
rolle
in sachsen ist der fluss schwarze elster
komplett ausgetrocknet tausende fische
sind verendet das klima ändert sich
offenbar rapide jetzt zu dir norbert und
einem überraschenden comeback in der
formel 1 nico hülkenberg ist wieder da
der 32 jährige deutsche ist heute beim
team racing point für den krone
erkrankten sergio perez eingesprungen im
freien training zum großen preis von
großbritannien in silverstone früher die
achtschnellste zeit über der garage
prangt noch das porträt des mexikaners
im racing point boliden aber sitzt
rückkehrer nico hülkenberg des neuer
arbeitsplatz erst mal angepasst werden
muss nicht einfach für den deutschen vor
allem der umgang mit einem neuen
komplizierten lenkrad immerhin fährt
hülkenberg vor seinem 178 grandprix die
achtschnellste zeit in beiden
trainingsläufen team kollege lance
stroll heute überraschend schnellste
sebastian vettel beschwert sich über
lose teile in seinem ferrari und legt
anschließend sogar noch selbst hand an
vettel auf platz 18 und sichtlich
bedient
erst andre schürrle nun benedikt höwedes
binnen zwei wochen haben zwei
weltmeister von 2014 ihre
fußballkarriere beendet der langjährige
ex verteidiger von schalke 04 stand bei
der wm in brasilien die kompletten 600
90 spielminuten auf dem platz und im
endspiel gegen argentinien
ja da wäre ihm fast ein kopfball tor
gelungen aus familiären gründen so hügel
ist wurde er jetzt seine karriere
beenden
geglückte generalprobe für bayern
münchen vor dem champions league
achtelfinal rückspiel gegen chelsea in
gut einer woche der testspielgegner
heute oder im pick marseille neuzugang
lehrer seine musste zuschauen da ihm die
spielberechtigung in der champions
league fehlt seine kollegen beherrschten
masse auch so sehr schnabel mit dem 1 0
in der 20 minute das olympic nach
abgebrochener französischer saison noch
spielpraxis fehlt konnten die bayern
zwar zu keinem weiteren treffer nutzen
vorstandsmitglied oliver kahn regte
dennoch zufrieden
das lächeln immer mit die hitze bleibt
uns auch morgen erhalten nur kommen noch
gewitter dazu die details hat gleich
osten tatli claus kleber freut sich auf
sie im heute journal um 10 und wir sagen
machen sie sich ein schönes wochenende
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
ein show guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter von westen her
wird allmählich diese kurze und
intensive hitzewelle allmählich beendet
schauer und gewitter ziehen mit einer
kaltfront auf und die sehen sie hier
gleich wie sie langsam nach deutschland
ziehen und dann sich weiter nach osten
durchsetzen
in der nacht in der zweiten nachthälfte
in den frühstunden wird es dann von
westen her die ersten schauer und
gewitter geben ansonsten bleibt es aber
größtenteils trocken temperaturen sinken
an der oder auf elf bis 10 grad richtig
kühl hier im vergleich zum westen hier
im ruhrgebiet um die 22 grad also das
kühlt kaum ab morgen im tagesverlauf
dann einzelne aber heftige gewitter mit
platzregen hagel und sturmböen gut
möglich ansonsten im osten größtenteils
sonnig das bei temperaturen noch einmal
im süden bis 37 grad von westen her aber
nicht mehr ganz so heiß um 31 23 grad an
der ostsee deutlich kühler
die nächsten tage am sonntag dann
weitere kräftige gewitter im osten und
im süden deutschlands bis 28 grad ja
oder am montag an den alpen teils
dauerregen und dann wehrte 17 bis 23
grad
damit ein schöner abend